this season on orange is the new black
they gave your character a love interest
a girlfriend a girlfriend yeah
Beth Dover we have a picture of you with
best over here and she's lovely lovely
and so hot as [ __ ] let's face it yeah
yeah well okay let's let's talk first of
all you guys have scenes together mm-hmm
as an actor do it does it help when you
are really attracted to the person I
imagine yeah I mean who wouldn't want to
go down and Beth Dover I'm in
Nathan Lane would go down on better I am
an actor honey if you pay me enough
money I'll go down on a table leg yeah
and I will make you believe that I am in
love with that table leg the list in
your agents office of what you go down
within the price range yeah sure so like
okay so and you because you've been very
open about this before you you've said
that obviously you're very attracted to
to women but you slept with men as well
you [ __ ] yeah well I'm a certain age
of a certain generation so gold stars
are very rare in my generation so I had
to hold not not what one would say a
whole bunch of them but I've seen by
Sheriff you know that that's not what I
want you just described he just you did
you just described us both actually
really have you took me a long time to
figure it out
so I'm saying please tell me you took
video oh yeah it's out there we were
trying to find it so so okay so for
example your co-star on on the show who
you have a love interest with Beth Dover
the fact that you're attracted to her
makes it like it makes it probably
enjoyable to have those scenes yeah I
definitely got a little woody while we
were having those scenes or in my case a
wide on yeah again I'd like to point out
this show is primarily for children
being simulcast Nickelodeon right now
you